We live in a world where we don't read
the code anymore. The only way to really
combat that is to have some
understanding of what the code does post
execution. [music] Everyone is giving
you different levels of observability.
Your job as an engineer is to go figure
out what works for you. So your agents
can understand what actually happened.
Does all of this eventually loop back
and now Claude can actually close the
loop and you can build a better and
better system so you can have alignment
in what you expected versus what
happened. Hey everyone, today's episode
is going to be about observability. And
the thing I find most fascinating about
observability is how we actually went
through and we're able to go and build
these black boxes now with code that we
either don't read or are
non-deterministic because they use LMS
and therefore have some level of
expected failure and hit rates. And the
most close analogy that we really relate
to is distributed systems and how we
actually built distributed systems. we
go a little bit into the history of how
we did metrics, wide logs, um, and user
expectations to eventually build a fully
probing system. One of the cool things
that we'll talk about is how to actually
build full tracing execution and what an
example of that looks like so that you
can get full call stacks and really
deeply have both you and Claude
introspect your code traces. But the
most important part is the value of
tracing, which is how you can go from
design to code to post execution and
build a closed loop system that helps
you better align with your agents. Let's
get started.
>> Let's do it, baby. Welcome to the AI
that works show. Uh, where Vibob
definitely always shows up on time. Uh,
my name is Dex. I am the CEO and
co-founder of Human Layer. We help you
solve hard problems and complex code
bases with AI. And I am joined by Vibv,
the CEO. I guess he's just co-founder of
of Boundary ML where they make a
programming language for AI and the AI
era and for AI agents and uh yeah, what
was your biggest takeaway from AI
engineer last week?
>> I think a lot of people are extremely
stressed about the quality of their code
bases over time. It seems to be a source
of anxiety for almost every human I've
met from the best engineers to the worst
engineers.
>> I agree. Yeah, that was kind of the
whole software factory theme was like
everyone had their own solution to how
do we fight slob? How do we how do we
let how do we use AI to help us ship
code without like screwing it up? And
it's like you had the people who said
just do more code review agents. They
say just do more linting. You had you
and Eric who were both like we need new
programming languages. Eric's languages
were more like alien space languages
that Jeff Huntley predicted. Uh I think
yours is a little more sane and uh you
know continuous innovation rather than
discontinuous. But um yeah I uh I think
software 2026 is going to be the year of
no more slop by hell or high water. We
are going to figure out how to make it
happen as a as as an industry.
>> I think we're going to have something
happen. I don't know if it's going to be
no slop, but I think we're going to get
further away. And I do think a lot of
people are feeling
>> Yeah.
U I think a lot of people are feeling a
lot of the anxiety of what like
their code base are devolving into. I
have another question for you. When you
had the opportunity to go talk about
human layer at the conference, what do
you think resonated the most? I think
there's this weird like the there's this
like spectrum of people's maturity with
AI and their LM intuition and like their
their proclivity to the hype machine and
things like this of like where are you
along your journey of like oh this
really works or no it doesn't and like
it's kind of like you know the midw
curve of like no I need six t- buck
sessions and I need this and I need that
and like the end of the curve is like
nope just read the code and make good
software there's a lot ofcept acceptance
that you know I think someone came up to
me and said 70% of the people at this at
this conference are actually like early
in the journey and they're like really
excited about whatever is being hyped
right now and there's about 30% of
people who have like yep seen that tried
that been doing that for a year doesn't
work like I am I am past that and like
so I don't know the biggest takeway for
me is like there's such a broad spectrum
of of AI and AI maturity and it's I know
on this show we work really hard to kind
of like cut through the hype and give
you stuff that actually works. And I
think that's like more important now
than ever. And I don't know, it's it's
hard to both like it's the broader the
audience and the broader like the
things. This is like a teaching in
general. It's like you have to you have
to know who you're talking to and who
you're trying to serve and uh it's
getting complicated. I think I uh I just
want to shout out a few folks like um I
know a few folks came up to both me and
Dex at the conference of like you guys
have been longtime fans and like have
been tuning in. Um I was as a founder
that was so cool. That was so cool to
just experience and have you guys come
out here um and just say hi and like
it's awesome to know that it's this is a
fun conversation you guys are tuning in
to.
>> I think I got Vibb hooked. He's never
been to an AI engineer conference before
and I think we're going to get him to
come to the rest of them. So, if you
want to uh hang out with us, uh go to
the AI engineer event near we're not
going to go to every single like I'm not
going to Singapore. It's too far.
>> But if you're an AI engineer in New
York, if you're an AI engineer Miami,
we're going to try to make it to I'm I'm
going to try to make it to all of those
because I I I love the crowd and
attracts really really smart people and
I always learn a ton. So, uh if you want
to hang out with us, AI engineer,
>> I think for me, uh I had a really
interesting takeway. It's actually
related to today's topic. So, uh, when I
was talking a lot about BAML, a topic
came up pretty often, which is like
observability. And I know everyone talks
about observability, but today I kind of
want to both whiteboard a few things and
also talk about stuff from like more
like first principles around
observability.
And really the reason that observability
came up really high is because when I
think about observability in today's day
and age, I actually think of it as the
only way to understand our codebase. And
Dexter, I'd love your thoughts on this
as we chat more. But when I think about
it, it's like look, I don't read every
line of code anymore. I' I've been
saying this for a bit. I I basically
stop reading the code. I read a lot. I
read some of it. I read invariants. I
read the very low layers. I read the API
surface area, but I don't read every
line of code. It's too much pain in the
ass.
>> Do you want to see what I read?
>> You read your specs?
>> No, I read We actually We added this
thing to Human Layer recently that is
like a PR walkthrough. Have you seen
this?
Let me find uh let me find a big one.
Keep keep going. I'll I'll find you a
good one. Keep keep talking about what
you read and what you don't.
>> I think when we live in a world where we
don't read the code anymore, the only
way to really combat that in my opinion
is basically to have some understanding
of what the code does post execution.
Uh it's kind of like how if you ever
have a website, the way that you
understand how your website is working
or not is not by like reading the code
of the website. You literally just look
at the funnel. You look at engagement
rates and that tells you all the data.
But now I think we kind of have to do
that for all systems, not just u uh not
just uh AI systems.
>> Let me let me let me let me get you this
example real quick.
Um wait, where did it go? Did it just
did it literally just close the tab? God
damn it. All right. all systems, not
just AI systems.
>> So like let's say we have a block of
code here and effectively it operates as
like a black box and as long as a black
box keeps on like giving you like
correct I guess blue box as long as a
blue box keeps giving you like correct
outcomes as far as you're concerned
that's kind of all you measure. You're
basically like how many of the how many
of the outcomes that we do for like user
A user B encountering this scenario how
many of them work? And at some point you
go down this road. You're like, "Okay,
well we have 10 that are working." And
at some point some user comes along and
says, "Hey, this stuff doesn't work."
And they report some bug. And what you
really measure as an end user. Uh at
least the way I think about this is you
measure like how often is someone
getting an undesired outcome out of
this. And and
>> right this was we started with like
uptime. This was like what appex was,
right? Aptex was this proprietary metric
that now everyone has which is like just
a number from zero to 100 uh or actually
it's like 99.9 it's like two decimal
places of like how how how often are
user getting disappointing results and
it was like a com combination of
response time and error rates and all
this stuff that gave you kind of this
onelevel picture of like is it is it
good and what percent of people are not
having
>> said he stole my thunder that's why I
drew through it this way cuz my next
boss is to exactly do this. It's like
[laughter] this is exactly how we do
distributed systems. If you guys think
about this um we basically have this
metric uh because it's impossible to
know the status of a distributed system,
you can only measure it as it exists at
any given time.
>> And what you really do as you become a
bigger and bigger company is instead of
measuring one system, you actually start
measuring subsystems as well.
uh and you basically start building all
these metrics and all these things that
say like how well is your system
performing over time rather than just
like a single part of your system uh and
now all of a sudden you've built GitHub
and now you have you eventually
hopefully end up with uh five nights of
uptime though that's very hard um and
obviously as your system gets well the
problem is what ends up happening is as
your system evolves and the thing about
regular software
>> is this doesn't happen very much your
system doesn't typically evolve the way
your users use distributed system is
very generally stable and predictable
over time and we've seen exactly what
happens when it becomes unpredictable.
For example, in the case of GitHub, more
code is being pushed to GitHub than they
ever predicted at a rate that they could
not have modeled. Like you could it is
impossible to go back to 2021 and say we
are going to push this much code into
GitHub. it like it would be an insane
bet to go make that bet just like it
would be an insane bet to go back to
2021 and say we're gonna need this much
RAM in the environment. So, we need to
start building these factories in like
2017 or 2020 so that we have RAM today.
>> It's just not going to happen. [snorts]
>> If I if I came to you in in 20 2021 and
said I'm going to thousandx the number
of software developers by 2025, you
would have been like
>> it's just not going to happen. uh
there's like a curve and you fit the
curve and you there's some like ratio
that you go do this. So effectively what
happens is when your distributed system
no longer models your system, what ends
up happening is you basically just
suddenly start getting way worse uptime.
And if you go back um yeah I mean any
company at a trillion dollar valuation
2020 2019 was crazy. It's just not what
you expected. Um but if you go back
>> to this kind of system and started doing
this,
>> think about how this works for agentic
systems. We kind of have the same thing.
Except the big difference here is except
your end user.
This this funny little person over here.
Um, can I draw?
How can I draw on here? Sorry.
>> You can do whatever you want, man.
>> This end user.
>> I loved the stick figures in your
presentation. This is what Excaladraw
was meant to be used for. I use JS Paint
just to be very clear. Um, this end user
over here, the only problem is, uh, this
end user is a lot more dynamic than
distributed systems are. And that makes
a huge difference because as this end
user, they're suddenly going to push in
a whole bunch of dynamic inputs into
your actual agentic system or your non
your basically your vibecoded slop that
you built over here. Um, and like I
don't say that in a bad I generally mean
this with love. I think everyone's going
to have more vibecoded slot than ever
before. And every single time this user
does this, you're going to have a lot
more reds. And the better and the better
and more capable you make your system,
ironically enough, the more reds you'll
have. And the more reds, go ahead.
>> Well,
>> well, the reason I say this is not
because your system is bad. It's because
a user is going to start building
effectively insane expectations about
what your system will do and it'll just
have more and more unmet expectations
because what you're really doing is
you're building like oh my god nope
wrong thing. You're basically building
this chart of like what the you what
your system can do and it's going like
this. But as your system gets better the
user's expectation of what your system
can do is going like this. So what's
really happening and the reason that
you're getting more reds is not because
your system is not getting better or
because the models aren't getting
better. The reason that you're happening
is this discrepancy is really what
you're really trying to like fight. It's
like what is the amount of delta that
the user is perceiving between what your
system it thinks your system can do
versus what it can actually do. And this
it's I think in the world that we're
headed towards today the user system is
going to go up.
And in this world and like my opinion is
that the only way to actually understand
the system is basically to have more and
more probing points through arbitrary
points in your software. So instead of
having a single uptime number, you
actually have many uptime numbers. You
have many implicit understandings of
exactly where your codebase is failing.
So then you can say something like oops.
So then you can say something like this.
It's like, hey, this is our uptime for
this section of the graph,
but that doesn't mean it's the same
exact uptime for this section of the
graph. And being able to introspect your
codebase at this level of granularity, I
think is the only way to truly go and go
do this. And I'll talk about a whole
bunch of like ways that we can talk
about this in a second. But I just I
first wanted to talk about like the phil
uh philosophy behind this. What are your
thoughts on this guys?
>> Yeah, this is this this is Andy Grove,
right? This Andy Grove's whole thing was
like I mean this was Intel a while ago.
This was not really about measuring
software. It was about measuring like
teams and people and processes, but it
was like treat it like a black box and
then when the black box no longer serves
you and you have to open the box like
maybe you put windows on the box, you
put little slits on where like the old
school observability is like you would
just like emit a couple metrics, right?
You would have like four numbers that
would just tell you like what's the
average time to do this? What's the
average rate of X? And so you're like
kind of poking slits in the box and then
eventually you're just like what you're
saying is like it's so complicated and
so random and so so like just the the
amount of different cases going in that
it's it's not enough to just poke slits
in. You kind of have to be able to
really look at every single thing that's
happening inside.
>> And the reason for this is like the
problem is once someone reports a bug,
as sad as it is, this metric is only
useful in hindsight. You can't have
foresight about what the problems is.
And if you did know what the foresight
is, then like great, just fix the
problem because just ask an agent, it'll
fix the solution for you. But if you
>> and this this was actually like if you
want you want to do a little more
history here
>> like so like the thing you used to have
was like here I'm gonna go off to the
right here was like you had basically
like the number the the the key the the
first thing we had was like when data
was expensive and memory was expensive
we had metrics
>> and so you literally had like one number
and you could say you know for for a
given server you know the what's the
error rate right and it would be good
and then it would pop up and then it
Come down, right? Oh my god. I can't do
the drawing thing. We're going to do
this one.
>> No, you got to have art, man. Artisal
art. Anyway, go on. Okay.
>> No. So then you could say, okay, for
server one, it looks like this. And for
server two, it looks like this. And like
you would just look at like, yeah, the
error rate for different things. Uh, and
and and you would just draw like, you
know, what is one one number per thing
you cared about and you would have like
a couple hundreds of these and you would
make dashboards with this stuff. Uh and
so your your data would basically look
like you know time stamp it was time
series right so you would have like a
time stamp and then you had you know
like 1s 2s 3s like into something I
don't know these are these are all dates
right
>> yeah exactly
>> and then you would just have like values
right and so you would say you know like
server one yeah thank you
>> yeah you'd basically just collect a
bunch of data for various servers or
various processes or various devices and
just basically try and slice and dice
them in some meaningful way.
>> Yep. Uh and so these would be like value
one.
>> Uh and then what we got to in like the
mid like basically like what Facebook
did with scuba and then charity majors
came and took and turned into like what
like they basically she coined the term
observability, right? Uh and so
observability was basically like instead
of just having metrics have what we call
like wider data like the the journey of
observability is like hardware and
storage and like software gets better
and more performant and we can store
more stuff without knowing what we want
and so you have like you can store like
user ID and you can store you know error
message and you're basically like
storing this why is this like this hold
on let me left justify this you you
start storing this like event data
basically basically where you have like
tons and tons of fields of like
team ID,
region and so like basically instead of
manually having to like decide what your
dimensions are like in this case you
store the timestamps for servers and
then you also store the time timestamps
for like you know service
service one service 2 like basically
spread ac if you have if you have uh
let's say you have like you know this
was like old old old pre-cluster days,
but you have like server one
and server two. And so the only
dimensions you have were like what
service was it? What server was it on?
And then you have like service one
running here and you have service two
running here.
>> I got something
>> and let's say you only have service one
over here. Does that make sense?
>> Talks about this and this basically just
is a great tear down of why you want
observer wide events. But like it
basically just talks about this and
talks about how you want to go get wide
events for all the unknown unknowns. And
the graphics he does here are like
>> yeah it's way easier to debug if you can
store all of the data and then go figure
out what you want later and query it
performantly and store it like without
taking up like billions of gigs of data.
>> Exactly. So this thing basically just
talks about this and says why you want
all this data. Um I'll link our linked
article. Boris is awesome. Um writes a
really good blog post about this stuff.
Why can't I send it? There you go.
>> Oh, yeah. This is better than mine.
>> Yeah, because this lets you correlate
across any dimension that you might want
to care about and you don't know what
the dimension is later. If it's like it
it makes it so much easier to find bugs
if it's like, oh, all the users that
have this thing is true, uh, that's
that's the thing that actually
correlates with the spike.
>> And and the most important thing for
everyone to really understand here is
not anything specific about this. It's
the most important thing to really
understand here is that when you do
observability of any kind,
observability is not useful at all for
things you already know. Observability
is useful in hindsight. When you like
why do we have these uptime metrics? Why
don't we just start with a standard
number and why do we break them down
more? It's because when something goes
down, you want to quickly be like, hey,
the main system is down because the
database is down. And boom. You want you
want to have that answer. You don't want
to be debugging it at that time. You
don't want your users or Dexter this
beautiful agent diagram like our users
are now not obviously just humans. So
let's write this down. We also have
agents using it. You want agents to be
able to understand the spec as well. So
the only thing you can find useful is
effectively hindsight observability.
And that's like the big that's kind of
the big argument that I want to push the
world towards more personally, which is
you want to be able to make your entire
black box observable because if you
don't make it observable, then you can't
have handset observability. And in order
to do that, you have a couple of
different options. And one of those
options just like
how do I zoom in?
one of those options like you're going
to write a bunch of code like service
API server service API
that does something who I don't know
what this router does but like uh like
hello route
uh you're going to build a bunch of
these routes as you go down this road
and as you build this route one of the
things that I recommend that you do for
all your top level API just like add
some sort of tracing on top of it it's
super lowhanging it's super trivial, but
it'll just make it so that when
something goes wrong, even if you don't
understand it, you can go do this and
just like ask an LM to go do this. Add
some llinter to guarantee this.
>> That's funny.
>> My one of my first projects that I built
uh at Sprout back in like 2015 was this
thing called instrumented where you
would like it would like take the
function name and it would emit like 15
metrics basically.
>> Uh this was based on like Kota Hail's
metrics, right? You would have like uh
you would have a meter for like you
would have like a counter for how often
it is getting called
throughput. You would have a timer for
like the histogram of like histogram of
latency.
[snorts]
>> You would have a counter for errors. Uh
and so you could do thing you could
compute things off of this like error
rate equals you know throughput over
errors or errors over throughput, right?
>> Yeah. Uh and you can look at like the
P99 and etc. And so like basically and
and and the histogram here like the the
the histogram every single thing is a
different metrics P50, P90,
P98, P99, etc.
Um and tracing is like you should talk
about what tracing really is like you
should draw a trace or do you have a do
you have a trace floating around
somewhere of like
>> I do I have a I have one that's
available right now. Yeah, because I
would say like distributed tracing was
the next hot thing after we got into
wide data sets. Like that was the thing
that people built on top of wide data
sets was like hotel traces, open
telemetry traces.
>> So I'm just going to show something
because that's probably easier.
>> You got waterfall. You got a waterfall
for me?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'll just run this for
example. It doesn't really matter what
this pipeline does. I'm just going to
run this really fast.
>> This is like some image gen thing,
right?
>> Yeah. I mean it's called generate
images. So I really hope it generates
images. [laughter] Um otherwise it's
named poorly. But you're seeing a bunch
of functions here. This function uh
uh this function for example you can see
what it does. It basically is like it
generates an image then evaluates an
image and then while the score is low it
does that in a loop and eventually
returns the image that it finds uh if
it's less than three attempts. Do you
kind of get the gist of what the code is
doing? But uh I'm going to show you what
what we really want with tracing because
once you have tracing there's a lot of
things in here. Obviously, this is using
a lot of functions that we don't know.
We haven't read the code for any of
these. We don't know what HTTP calls
we're making. We have no almost no
introspection on any of this data.
>> Yeah. In the old days, if I wanted to in
the old days, if I wanted to debug this,
I'd be like jumping to definition and
clicking around and like, okay, let me
go read this function body to understand
what happens. Okay, let me go click into
another function to understand what
happens. And like building this all into
my head of like, okay, how do these
things fit together? Where are the slow
parts? Where are the errorprone parts,
etc.?
>> Yeah, exactly. And when I really Why is
it running so many? I have three
attempts.
Did I have a Oh, I'm dumb. I don't
increase attempts by one firstly. Like,
so I just want to show again like how do
you find bugs with tracing? Well,
>> well, this is at the very least logs.
>> This is this is tracing actually. I'm
dumping out the tracing values here. But
first things first, let's let's uh
cancel this function. Um
Oh, I'm sorry. All right, we don't have
plus+ because++ is silly. We should
probably add plus+.
Um,
as I go do this, I'm going to cancel
this.
>> Yeah, your agent tries BAML didn't find
that.
>> I didn't run this anyway. Um, so as I
run this, the first thing to notice is
like one really nice thing that you get
with really nice tracing is you can
build really nice tools like this. You
can clearly be like and watch.
>> Can we start with the trace before we go
to the UI you built on top of the trace?
>> Yeah, here we go.
>> We'll just do full screen. Let's open
the flame graph and just look at this
thing.
Uh let's go here.
>> If you scroll down, you have this
waterfall thing, right?
>> Yeah. And the waterfall thing basically
tells you exactly how much you're
spending and what things. And if you've
ever seen like a flame graph or
something like that, you can think of as
a uh sorry, I'm going to rerun this
because uh I lost the
>> Yeah, that's a big old
>> Yeah, I lost the source maps.
>> Oh, because you edited the file.
>> Uh yeah. Yeah. So, we have we'll work on
doing this. But um when this runs
this time, it's bounded to three, so it
should be faster. But like the first
value of tracing that you really get is
like the minute you start tracing,
finding bugs is so much easier because
the minute you can find bugs is how do
you find bugs? Well, even as the program
is executing without waiting for
completion, I realize that something is
off here because it should take three
attempts and boom, I can trace it very
fast. So if you think about your
production applications and users
getting un unexpected behavior, if you
can expose tracing to your users or
something like that, your users can
actually help diagnose and build the
right system automatically.
Let's go here. Uh, what is going on?
Sorry.
>> All right, we're going to run it one
more time.
>> One more time. Beta software. Um, but
and I'll talk about hotel and stuff in a
second, too. And I'll talk about LM
tracing as general because LM tracing I
think is slightly different than regular
tracing, but I think it's people are
treating as too different than regular
tracing.
>> Uh, it's different in some senses, but
most
>> how many hotel how many startups are
just hotel rappers billing themselves?
It's like, well, this is special. You
need you need to do it differently for
LLMs.
>> Yeah, it's like and I'll talk about
hotel in a second. I have a whole huge
bunch of gripes at the hotel, but it I
think the key part that you really want
to have is when you go look at this
flame graph and you go start
understanding what the code is actually
doing. You want to be able to really
quickly understand exactly where time is
being spent, where error rates are
happening, what's not happening as you
expect. Uh and like you could imagine
this is just a dimension. We Dextra
talks about wide events. If you want to
understand cost, you want to understand
how many times you call something out.
>> Well, technically technically cost and
time are metrics and the dimension is
like function name or or module or
whatever it is.
>> Yeah, sure. You want to be able to index
by function name or something else, but
like
>> obviously you're going to use packages
that you don't own. You want to be able
to understand what packages you don't
own that are being called by the system
and be able to really quickly like grab
through them
>> without having to go debug anything but
not have to look at them every single
time. But what you really want is the
minute think about how an LM works and
think about how all of you are going to
think about this code. None of you
actually know what happens under the
hood in these functions. You just know
at some point we call generate image.
But now you can actually really quickly
see what you call with generate image.
It calls it calls a thing called prompt.
It calls a thing called dot call
function. And eventually it goes to all
of this. It gets some environment
variables over here. Um, and eventually
eventually it calls HTTP.
And it makes an HTTP request. And you
can even see very fast that the bulk of
the time is actually being spent um on
like this. Oh, where'd it go? Um, on
this actual send request over here.
There's another one. Oh, waiting for
Okay, because there's an await here or
something. But the bulk of his time is
actually being spent Oh. Oh, sorry.
Sorry, the bulk of this time is actually
being sent on this like underscore send
which send calls under the hood and
without you sorry this is latency on the
right side. This is when it started.
This is like the time step when it
started and you can quickly see exactly
where it was being called without
understanding. So without any guessing
without digging through the codebase
without understanding the code ahead of
time with tracing and really in-depth
tracing you can actually go through and
figure out exactly what's happening and
where your bug might be. And I think
this is really the magic of what we want
with these sort of systems. Like when we
go back to like these total black boxes
that we don't understand, you really
want to go back in hindsight and say,
"How the heck do I understand what
happened when things went wrong?" Well,
what do you do? You pull up, you need to
pull up some sort of tracing system. And
the usefulness of this is merely a
function of how much tracing you were
able to tag on when you ship the code.
>> Yeah.
>> Does that make sense, Dexter?
>> Yeah. I I think of like the difference
between tra like what I would have done
before and like we'd spent a lot of time
in 2014 like sshing into servers and
like tailing and gpping logs for stuff
is like logs was the earliest version of
this. you had logs and then you had
metrics and then like now the like the
the story is like okay logs metrics
traces that's the full observability
story and they all have kind of
different purposes and different levels
of granularity but yeah no I remember
when we turned on New Relic in 2014 and
it was like oh now I don't have to read
the logs and put in special logging to
figure out what's slow because the trace
is just going to capture everything and
be like yep this is the bad SQL query
this request made 40 different SQL
queries and this is the one that's slow
and then you're like cool let me go fix
that.
>> Yeah, exactly. And I think that's the
general list and like every now and then
for certain types of functions you want
to capture both the inputs and the
outputs. Sometimes you only want to
capture the inputs, sometimes you only
want the outputs, sometimes you want the
error rates and everything else. And I
think this granularity of being able to
choose what you want is basically
effectively what you want to happen.
It seems like the tracing like the idea
behind tracing is like you actually want
to keep everything because the the idea
of trace is like when we run traces in
production in human layer we we do a
pretty high sample rate like the the
traces are not about like hey I need to
debug every single individual request.
It's like I need to understand the shape
of this thing and I need like a very
quick again it's all about like how do
you how do you create things that are
easy for humans to consume and
visualization is a huge part of that.
How do I make it obvious without me
having to read logs or think or read
charts and graphs and just be able to
see immediately like oh that's the thing
that's low
>> actually Kota has another really good
talk about this of like
>> how do you build tools for humans how do
you build tools where it's like I can
use my what is it like system one
thinking the thing that like looks at a
wall that is white and like knows it's
white without even having to like
process it versus like the part of my
brain if you ask me to multiply two
three-digit numbers I like turn on and
like focus and so how do you make as
possible just like obvious
analytical part of your brain until you
you want to save that energy for the
most important stuff. And if you can if
you can make it easy to tell just by
looking at something then like that's
that's a great tool for humans.
>> Yeah. And you can kind of see exactly
what's happening here. Like the inputs
the images are basically evolving over
time and it's very easy to go grasp that
without reading a single line of
tracing. But effectively all of it needs
to be powered by something that is
extremely rich. So any question an agent
asks, like you want the agent to ask
like did I call send? Did I did I make
an HTTP request? And you as a human
don't want to think about this. You
literally want the agent to be like,
hey, search through all the function
calls that I made in this call stack.
Was any of them HTTP.end
and how many times was http.send called?
>> You're talking about feeding traces to
an agent, not to a human. Basically like
less the visual part, but more the like,
okay, how do I give my agent the ability
to like, cool, here's a thing someone
complained about. go look through the
traces and figure out what the problem
is.
>> Exactly. So, like if I'm a human and I'm
looking at this, it's like this is
useless. Let's be real here. Like this
is like useless is such a strong word.
Um
I often find myself when I interact with
Claude and I have a giant document in
front of me, I'm like, "Claude, can you
please give me the last three the three
most important things I should read in
this document?" I just let Claude do a
lot of digestion for me. I think uh and
really should I read the whole document?
Yes. And for really important documents,
I do read the whole document. But same
with traces. It's impossible for me to
expect that I'm gonna I'm as a human,
I'm going to go debug this unless it's
like critical to some major thing that's
happening. Almost definitely what's
actually going to happen is I'm going to
ask Claude, "Hey Claude, can you tell me
what's going on so I can go read this I
can go read this and inspect this on my
own."
Uh, and like I want claw to like tell me
what line I should jump to, for example,
instead of reading it on my own. So when
I think about I think this is like the
big highlight that I wanted to go show
everyone is like when you think about
how to build tracing for your system,
trace every little thing, you can store
every little thing that you can get
access to. And like obviously I'm very
opinioned on this like we built the
whole thing around tracing, but even in
your own code like just do it. spend the
cost, spend the thing because like your
system is almost definitely going to
have unexpected redness on here. And if
you don't have these introspection
points, you have zero chance of being
able to debug the issue later. And we
had this really clever idea. For
example, storing values is very
expensive. It slows down the program. It
uh it does a whole bunch of stuff. If
you wanted to copy these values and copy
them somewhere, it's like
>> you may be making a you may be making a
network request to send the traces
somewhere and if you have very high
performance application then you're now
using you know some of your network IO
some of your CPU cycles just to record
the other things that that might be
slow.
>> Yeah. Or saving to disk or anything like
that. Yep. So like what you really want
to do is by default you don't want to
capture values at all and then unless
something is like extremely dynamic. So
in our case the compiler knows whenever
you're interacting with a function it
calls an LLM. Boom. As soon as you
interact with an LM we store the input
outputs.
>> And of course we do a bunch of dduping.
So if you pass the same image around we
don't like copy and paste the image like
60 times.
>> But this is kind of how you can get
extremely fast performance without
having to worry about performance
effectively.
And that makes a huge difference. in
terms of like being able to like
introspect a program without any extra
work. We know fetch calls are like
interacting with external systems. So
fetch calls get recorded.
>> We also know headers are really risky.
So by default we don't save headers,
>> right? Because they may be authentic
stuff in there. Yeah,
>> exactly. So we just like store them. We
know environment variables are risky. So
any environment variable value gets
automatically omitted. And there's a lot
of things like that that we just do by
default to make it safe. And like if
you're using Sentry or something else,
they do the similar kinds of stuff. But
most tracing systems, I think, are built
for error handling. And most proactive
telemetry systems are built very much
like users have to opt into it. And I
think that's really the fundamental flaw
in most tracing systems, which is users
have to go write something like
for every single function, you got to
like write this thing. And if you're
writing LM's writing all your code, then
like maybe an LM will write at trace
here. But is it really also going to
write trace there? probably not. And now
you just have a missing tracing system.
>> Yep. And you could even do the the the
even the dumber if you just do at log,
right? If you just want to log like time
stamp and when the function was called
and its arguments, right? Like you could
write all of this stuff and you could
build it. But doing this in a performant
way, in a way that is like the same
across every service you run is like
there's entire platform teams. I
remember when we got we kind of like
went from pets to cattle at at at
Sprout. It was kind of like okay instead
of having a server and it runs these
four things and this server over there
runs those four things we need like a
generic servicebased thing which always
has the same metrics endpoints and
health check endpoints and emits the
same like standard set of things. I mean
this was what the Google S book was all
about was like hey look we're going to
have a team and they're going to be on
call to help you with your services and
if things go down they'll fix them for
you. It's was trying to solve the the
the you know engineers ship something
and then DevOps DevOps has to cis admins
have to maintain it. It was like cool if
you build a service you're on call for
it. The engineers have to like own the
reliability of their stuff but the S sur
team has tools and if you meet a certain
bar if you like inject all of the shared
logging patterns and tracing patterns
and you do all the things then S can
take that service over and run it for
you. Um, and doing this at scale in a
way is like there's entire there's
entire giant teams inside any large tech
company that's all their job is to like
how do we equip people with tooling to
help them make their stuff more
observable and how do we make it so that
we can actually help even if we don't
really know if we haven't read all the
code inside the service.
>> Yeah. And you kind of want to be able to
write stuff like this.
User images.generate image where
uh orgs thing.length
is greater than 50 and latency metrics
>> one. Yeah. uh you kind of when you
really think about what you want out of
tracing, I think this is the feature of
what we really want. We want to be able
to write questions like find me
everything where it took more than one
second where the length or like what I
really
>> thing here is the prompt, right? It's
like the thing you asked to generate,
right?
>> Yeah. Well, thing is like yeah, I guess
this is the input argument to this
function specifically.
>> Yeah, it's a it's a really good variable
name, dude. I really like it.
>> I am uh I am known for my high quality
code. [laughter]
Uh but args is just like this is just
the name of the parameter in this
function. But what you really want over
here is you want to be able to write
this kind of query and you want all of
this to be type safe. You want to be
able to say like output is always going
to be an image. So it has B 64 and you
want the SQL query to tell you that. You
want to know args has a thing called
thing has a parameter called thing and
thing is a string type because if you
can do this
>> you want type safety on your on your
queries as well. You want to be able to
kind of like have a schema to query
against where any anybody can kind of
quickly riff this out or an agent can
quickly riff this out and basically like
very instead of doing like GP or reading
whole files, you want to be able to
really just pull out the things you care
about.
>> Yeah. And you want this to look
effectively as similar to your um
as similar to your code as possible. So
like I have generate image. You want
this to basically mimic exactly what
this code is. and you want it to look
very close to your code because then if
an agent can query the codebase out of
it, then what you end up with is a way
where like telemetry actually like means
something very reasonable and then this
tight loop of when you're probing this
actually means that hey this we can find
all the red instances in the first thing
because generate image failed here so
now we know obviously everything
downstream is obviously going to fail as
well and I think that's the kind of
tight loop that you need with
observability and when I talk about
observability that's what I think people
should be building for their systems.
They should trace everything. They
should go ahead and make sure their
tracing is tied very closely to lines of
code. And now you can start measuring
everything, starting to collect stuff.
Now, I'm going to show one last thing.
You know about hotel. Everyone knows
about hotel.
>> I'm going to show you hotel.
>> Um, and I and like if you've ever seen
hotel, are we getting the hotel rant?
I've gotten a piece of this. I'm ready
for the the formalized version of it.
>> I'll show that. Yeah, I'll show it to
you. So when you do hotel firstly hotel
does something amazing which is it has
wide events thank god that's amazing
the problem with hotel however is that
when you do wide events and you start
doing tracing you start collecting all
this data hotel is not very
how do I put this rich is a nice way to
put this
>> like the the density of information is
low right you're using a lot of JSON
using a lot of keys and and like okay
yeah you have the start And you're
hoping that the person And you're hoping
that the person that wrote something
wrote it in a very standardized way.
>> Yeah. It feels like hotel is is just
like a bunch of opinions on top of wide
events, right? It's like, okay, cool.
Like yes, you're going to have arbitrary
things that you can attach to this like
attributes or properties, but also like
>> if you include these exact fields like
span and parent span and trace ID and
stuff, then you can get these like
specific specific visualizations.
>> Yeah, exactly. I know has really good
support for spans. But the real thing is
when you think about what types accepts,
this is what OTEL accepts.
String, boolean, int, float, sequence of
stir, sequence of bool, sequence of int,
sequence of float. And the fact of the
matter is because this is the type of
things that accepts, what people end up
doing most of the time is they do
>> put like B 64 JSON in there.
Literally what they do JSON I don't know
is it loads or like parse or two string
>> two string
>> don't pretend like you haven't written
Python in a while I know you know the
python it it's dumps
>> you don't know what it is
>> oh there you go dumps uh JSONd dumps for
value and now you get you basically just
store the JSON value as a string and
then you decode it on the receiving end
and hope that it's correct JSON
>> which means you can't query it
>> and what does
>> exactly which means no querying which
means that also So, um, think about how
much data you're sending across the
wire. So, we talked about performance
and like normally I hate talking about
performance
because, uh, performance is one of the
performance is not a thing that most
people should ever care about. But when
you're doing a massive amount of
observability and you want to literally
observe every single thing that you're
passing through the wire, if you're
sending like let's say you're sending
like a like a 100 bytes of actual data,
but then you JSON you turn it to a JSON
string and this blows up to about like
uh times 8 like 800 bytes.
This is strictly going to affect your
uptime. It's strictly going to affect
your performance rate of every single
piece of software. So when you blow
something up by 8x in terms of the
amount of data you're sending across the
wire, you suddenly stop being able to
trace everything and now you're making
trade-offs of [__] do Iel this one or
do Iel something else and it's always a
zero sum game and what you choose to
tell and what you choose to go around
this. So when you actually think about
how you want to do high performance
telemetry there, like you said, there
are entire companies that do this. And
if you look, there's like uh if you guys
haven't seen this, EVPF is like one way
to do this
or like uh I don't know if it's on here
where basically like tracks the system
traces to know exactly what call stacks
you're using and where you're spending
time without your process being
hammered. This lets you monitor
basically without without doing SIS
calls like it lets you it lets you
understand what's happening in the
kernel stack without actually like
leaving user land.
>> Exactly. So it makes your code faster
because you do and the reason people are
trying to solve these problems from many
different angles is because in a world
of LMS where a agents write all the code
and everything is non-deterministic
tracing is the only way to understand
all the data. The problem is you also
want tracing to have a really good
understanding of your shape of data.
like you want to understand and be able
to write this kind of query. And you
can't do that unless you actually like
embed tracing into your app. So like my
whole pitch today is like go write a
[__] ton of traces like in your codebase
and just vibe code the head out of it
and make it really easy for agents to go
query everything here. So if agents
can't query everything here every time
you get a re user bug, you can build a
really nice feedback loop to like ship
your updates much faster. That was the
whole point of today's conversation on
tracing observability. Uh please go do
it. Uh, and likely I suspect you should
probably not do it yourself. It's a
waste of time. Buy some vendor that
gives you tracing and just like plug it
in and make sure they're performant and
make sure they capture extremely rich
data and make sure they give you agent
uh integration on it.
>> I like it.
>> Um, I'll do one more thing. Uh, if uh
we're doing we're doing like small
onboarding sessions. I know Dexter came
to one of them. Uh, if you guys sign up
here, we can get you hooked up and uh
try it out. if you actually want to try
like the new tracing stuff that we do.
Uh we do it like roughly every Thursday.
But um we we're exploring the space a
lot. Tracing is like one of the things
I'm deeply deeply passionate about right
now. Uh because I want to make it fast
and I want to make it low memory and I
want to make it rich
>> and I want to have no tradeoffs.
>> And this comes back to that whole idea
of like what a lot of people are hacking
together. I think I saw something
probably last week of like here's how I
review code. And what I do is I let the
agent just vibe it out and riff it out.
And then I have it create an HTML file
per folder that explains the changes in
that folder at a high level in a way
that I can kind of it's like zooming out
of the code and g give me a way to
digest 2,000 lines of code in a minute.
And then if I want to drill in, I can,
but I want to get like the shape of
everything. And then they give feedback
on each report for each module or each
file and they proceed that way. And then
eventually they might dig into the code
and stuff. Um, and it seems like you're
kind of just trying to productize this
of like, hey, look, before you like you
will probably still end up reading code
sometimes in important places, but
before you go dig into the lines, how
can you be 10x or 100x more efficient
with your time and your mental energy to
get understanding of what is happening?
And I think that's where like
dynamically visualizing the code at the
programming language level is a really
like powerful idea for like okay how do
we understand what's happening uh as
quickly as possible and maintain the
ability to go drill down into the code
but also have this option to um just
kind of like cool I don't need to read
that I trust that that that's as as as
designed as expected and it's provable
it's not an LLM read something and then
decided and might have hallucinated or
might have misunderstood it's
deterministic based on the syntax that
was written.
>> Yeah. And like Dylan actually had this
great tweet.
>> I love this. This is in my presentation.
>> Yeah. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly. Uh
Dylan had this great tweet where he's
like the way he codes now he's just he
does basically like show me the call
stack.
>> And this is basically just hoping that
cloud code gives you this. And he's
basically building a tracing system in
some ways.
>> Well, this is part of planning, right?
This is before the code is written. He's
like, cool. like okay whatever we're
going to go build I don't need to see
every line of code but I need to
understand the type signatures and the
the objects that we're making and how
all these things fits together because
there's still I mean a lot of people are
happy to look at a mermaid diagram and
say like cool this looks good and look
at sequence diagrams say this looks good
but what we're finding and I think a lot
of people are finding is that LMS are
actually like even with system
architecture defined and aligned and you
and the you and the model have made a
plan for this you can still end up with
really bad code, sloppy code, bad
interfaces, like objects that overlap
each other, all these things that make
your software harder to maintain in the
long term and make it get you to the
point where it's like, oh, if I change
something over here, it breaks something
over there and you just get like slowed
down and kneecapped by the like
deterioration in code quality. So like
this is a layer that we're working a
lot. Also in human layer, we have this a
concept called like a technical design
doc. I think we did an episode about
this a couple weeks ago of like, no, you
should get into that level of basically
anything that you can't trust the LLM to
get right 99% of the time. It is worth
your time to align at this level of
abstraction because 5 minutes or 10
minutes doing this can save you hours.
when you get to code review and you're
like, "Oh, yes, it's it's correct and it
works and I went to the website and it's
good." But I know as someone who's like
worked in large code bases for 10 years,
okay, this is actually like not going to
set us up for success in even the medium
term, not even long term, like in in
four weeks, you're probably going to
start to regret that you merged that.
And so it's like, cool, where can we
find leverage? Where can we kind of like
make it so that instead of reading code
for an hour, I can read a doc for five
minutes
>> or see a visualization?
What's really interesting about this is
it's basically just like a spectrum,
right? Like you start from
you effectively start from like a
different place depending on what you're
trying to build
and like at some point what you do is
you you have tracing during planning
then you have tracing what the heck
happened then you have tracing like
during ad during like code effectively
like while the code is while the code is
like written.
>> Yep. Um so you have tracing during
planning or design phase. Then you have
tracing during the code and then you
kind of have the last layer which is
like you kind of want tracing uh where'd
he go
pipeline.
You kind of want tracing like during
execution is the way I draw this out.
>> Yep.
>> And it's kind of like we're all
basically talking about the same thing.
You basically have this like spectrum of
tracing that we're trying to build.
>> Oh, sorry. I only see your Slack.
>> Oh, you don't see my Slack. Sorry.
Pull this up. Window. Entire screen.
There we go.
>> Yep. Okay.
>> It's like
>> this is kind of like the spectrum of
what we're doing. And the reason that
we're all doing this is really simply
because these systems are
non-deterministic. And the only way to
build like extremely rich systems is
literally to go ahead and build
different levels of introspection as you
go do this. Y
>> you need tracing design.
>> Yeah. You can't yolo it. You can't you
can't just write it without being able
to see it because like we are I mean
it's almost like a learning thing like
we're all learning what the frontier
here looks like and part of that it's
the same thing we do vibe valves, right?
It's just like just go run the thing and
see what it's like cuz you need to
develop intuition.
>> Yeah. And this is still vibe. Like
there's no way Dylan knows every line of
code that's happening in these boxes.
>> Yeah.
>> There's probably more functions than
these boxes. He's just at a high level
making sure the key parts are correct.
>> We should have Dylan on and do a do an
episode and he can talk about this and
>> Oh, I'd actually be really curious about
this. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> I mean, he has his own podcast about how
to do good engineering now. So, uh, you
know, I will I I will work on him.
[laughter]
>> Yeah. We did one podcast with Reese
Sullivan and suddenly he goes and is
like, "Oh, we're going to do one too
now." It's great. It's a good show. You
should go watch it. The first two
episodes are out there. They're a lot of
fun.
>> I actually really enjoy watching their
show. It's It's also a different thing.
Uh, it's Dylan. You can look him up on
Twitter. Here you go.
>> Yeah, he's a cl he's like a principal
engineer at Cloudflare. Super smart
dude.
>> Yeah, he's Yeah, I really like their
content. Uh but like effectively like
this whole episode is about
observability. Everyone is giving you
different levels of observability. Your
job as an engineer is to go figure out
what works for you and figure out how
you can add different layers. So you can
go from tracing during design, tracing
during visualizing the code and
understand your code so you don't have
to read every line of code and tracing
post execution. So your agents can
understand what actually happened and
does does all of this eventually loop
back? I don't know how to do the arrows,
Dexter.
>> Five five Click back
>> five.
>> Click.
>> Oh my god. I'll do it.
>> Can you do it for me? Thank you.
[laughter] So So like cuz then what you
can do is you can feed back an agent
into this loop. Uh you can't do it
either. Got them.
>> No excuse.
>> What you can do if you build this
tracing system.
>> There we go. What you can do if you
build a really nice tracing system is
you can go back and feed these logs in
and say, "Hey Claude, what's missing in
the design that made the actual trace
not be the call site you tried to draw
me?" And now Claude can actually close
the loop and you can build a better and
better system that and again it's all
about alignment. So you can have
alignment and what you expected versus
what happened.
>> It's good. I like it. That's a good
episode.